[Music]
thank you
the top stories live from the Sky News
City Studio
taking care of business Northern Ireland
industry hopes President Biden will give
its trade with the United States a boost
today
the movement will be in these spots
lights today as the president visits the
city and makes his keynote speech in a
few hours time
we'll be chatting with the executive
who's just taken charge at a leading
player in the Lloyd's Insurance Market
Helios underwriting
we'll find out whether the life science
sector is delivering us investor Novo
Holdings publishes its annual results
and can home tree group compete against
the big firms which currently dominate
the home repairs Market
thank you
good morning this is Ian King live in
our business and economic news from the
Heart of the City well the Prime
Minister will meet President Biden
shortly in Northern Ireland it's a
significant meeting as efforts continue
to restore the assembly and also deliver
a brexit deal through the so-called
Windsor agreement well in a moment I'll
be speaking with the Federation of small
businesses in Northern Ireland but first
we're going to go live to Belfast and
skies Kamali Melbourne
thank you very much for that Ian yeah
we're here at Ulster University where in
a few hours time President Joe Biden
will be giving a keynote speech laying
out his commitment to the 25th
anniversary of the Belfast Good Friday
agreement and also his hopes for the
region for the next 25 years he's
currently holding a meeting as Ian said
with the Prime Minister rishi's soon
Knack if he's got a pack schedule ahead
of him as he is here on the island of
Ireland let's bring in our senior Island
correspondent David Blevins who's here
with us throughout the morning and David
um President Biden is going to be
speaking in a couple of hours times he
said at Ulster University and what do we
expect to hear when he does stand up to
speak as a tricky political time here of
course with the executive not
functioning yes and just before he makes
his remarks here at Ulster University he
is going to meet with the five main
Party leaders including the dup leader
Sir Jeffrey Donaldson and that is the
party currently boycotting the power
sharing government over its problems
with the brexit Border in the Irish sea
which they don't believe the Windsor
framework has adequately addressed their
concerns about but in many ways the
Democratic unionist party is beyond the
reach of Joe Biden for two reasons they
regard him as a very pro-republican
that's Irish Republican as opposed to
American Republican president we've
heard some very strong views from the
ideal ideological wing of the party this
morning regarding that but in many ways
he's also beyond their reach because
they're in election campaign mode local
Council poll in Northern Ireland next
week and next month that I think that
means they will be hesitant about
returning to the power sharing agreement
partnering government quickly but I
think there will be subtle pressure
brought to bear by him talking up
America's commitment to uh economic
investment in Northern Ireland
capitalizing upon that potential if
there were to be a stable government
here and by focusing his attention on
the Next Generation here at the
University when Bill Clinton came 27
years ago the first to start visit he
was introduced to the Audience by a
young person when Barack Obama came back
in 2016 I think it was he was introduced
to the Audience by a young person I
think it's a fairly safe bet that we're
going to see Joe Biden introduced to the
Audience by a young person and we'll
find out at the first time David thank
you very much for now now as I said
President Biden is currently going to be
holding talks with the Prime Minister
Rishi sooner let's bring in our Deputy
political editor Sam Coates who is just
across the city
um covering those talks for us good
morning to you Sam so look President
Biden speaking to Rishi sunak of course
they'll be talking about the Windsor
framework and the anniversary of the
Good Friday agreement but there's also
other things on the agenda not least the
war in Ukraine
that's right I mean we should see like
trying to make the most of the visit by
President Biden it's the third time that
they've met today Richardson was on the
tarmac uh at Belfast airport last night
when Air Force One touched down just
before uh 10 o'clock the pair will be
meeting
um but this isn't a big moment in U.S UK
relations it's rather interesting
there's a Nuance around how both sides
are describing this morning's meeting
it's been called a bilateral coffee now
that's diplomatic code it's diplomatic
code for a meeting but perhaps not the
most in-depth one the most detailed one
uh that there's been partly uh number 10
would say because meeting Biden again a
couple of times in the next two or three
months of the state visit and at the G7
but also because perhaps today isn't
what it could have been because if
Stormont had been up and running as
David was just hinting at then President
Biden could be here writing checks
unlocking uh investment instead the US
president's going to be using this
moment just to sort of try and dangle a
carrot in front of unionists to get them
back in Stormwind and the U.S have been
very clear that the main item on the
agenda for President Biden is the
Northern Ireland peace process is what's
going on here and uh President Biden
also seeing uh although probably quite
briefly uh representatives of all the
main political parties here in Northern
Ireland so for the U.S side on the U.S
side the meeting with Rishi sunak uh
about what's going on here in Northern
Ireland but Rishi sunak has tried to use
this moment and his Newfound stronger
relationship with the US president to
transform uh Britain's position on the
world stage that wins a frame an
agreement about brexit about uh Northern
Ireland's Place uh uh after leaving the
European Union has really transformed
Rishi sinak's position on the world
stage and he'll be looking to show
diplomatic wins economic games coming
from that so although they're not going
to talk about the free trade agreement
between the UK US that's quite a long
way in the future there might be more
marginal gains does discussed about
individual small deals to do with
perhaps some minerals perhaps tackling
some of the subsidies that the U.S is
offering which Britain don't like ways
of sorting out that complication in the
in the relationship so small building
blocks today a brief meeting but still
important for Richie sunac to show that
he is reset the relationship with U.S
presidents in a way that no prime
minister in the last 10 years has done
okay so for now thank you and we'll get
more from Sam throughout the morning as
he gets details of what comes out of
that meeting that bilateral coffee being
held between the president of the United
States and Rishi sunak that's all from
us here for now we'll of course be back
live here in Austin University once the
president does arrive he's due to give a
speech at around one o'clock today and
we'll bring you that live here of course
on Sky News but for now from the team at
Belfast it's back to Ian in the city
thanks Kamali well joining me now is
Roger Poland he's head of the Federation
of small businesses in Northern Ireland
Roger very good morning to you obviously
it's been a few weeks now the dust has
settled uh post the Windsor agreements
is it too early to say whether this is
going to be a success
it probably is too early but I think
overall we've got a lot of very good
ingredients here it's up to us now to
take them and uh and produce something
very good with them the winter framework
I think it's I wouldn't say the dust has
settled on it yet I think it's still
being worked out we're still certainly
as a business organization looking for
answers it's how it's going to be uh
transposed and actually implemented and
I suspect that that's also what's
happening within some of the political
parties they've heard the the good very
warm positive encouraging words they now
want to see how is that detail going to
be translated into written texts that
they can then actually rely upon for
their trading so overall uh we're quite
optimistic without getting too much into
the weeds of the framework Roger what
kind of things do your members want
Clarity on
well one of the key ones is what will
the Green Lane and the Redland mean in
practice who will be able to use them
what burden of proof will they have to
have to to get access to them and what
if you have somebody who trades both in
Northern Ireland and Elsewhere on the
island of Ireland will they be forced to
use a red lane rather than having the
access to the smoother Green Lane those
are the sorts of details that businesses
are coming to us and asking can we get
clarity on we haven't yet got it but we
are assured that it is coming and I
suppose once we see it then we'll be
able to evaluate it properly now
obviously President Biden is in Northern
Ireland right now what kind of wins
would you be looking for from his visit
in terms of positives for business in
particular
well I was watching your footage there
and I saw him being very closely
shadowed to his side by the new special
economic Envoy for Northern end that
President Biden has appointed as Joe
Kennedy III now we met with him in
Washington about four weeks ago we
hosted a Roundtable board uh boardroom
lunch with him and had a good uh
conversation over a couple of hours with
him and then saw him several other times
during the course of that week he's
clearly getting about he's clearly
making good connections he understands
the business environment here and I
think we we look on the the fact that
he's been appointed in that role as a
huge asset for Northern Adam he's a real
opportunity for somewhere with only 1.9
million people to get a specially
appointed economic Envoy from the
largest market on the planet and we look
forward to building relationships
between him and the businesses here in
Northern Ireland who are looking to
trade in the U.S just as much as inward
investors coming in from the US to here
but we're here marking the 25th
anniversary Good Friday agreement and
it's interesting to notice the role that
business has played in those 25 years so
when we emerged from the troubles the
public sector here was very bloated
because of the situation we find
ourselves in but in those 25 years we've
now seen smes grow so that they employ
more people than all large businesses
and the entire public sector combined so
that I suppose is a Real Testament to
how getting peace put in place properly
with the right supports around it uh can
transform a situation and so we're now
looking we're moving beyond the peace
process into hopefully a planned
Prosperity process for the next 25 years
what sort of inward investment flows
have you received from the United States
in recent years
well we've got about 200 American
companies now operating in Northern
Ireland employing about 30 000 people so
again and the size of our population
that's a very very significant uh
investment that people have made but
it's also good the fact that there are
so many companies so it makes it a much
more robust type of relationship than if
it was just one very large investor so
very good uh start I think you've seen a
lot of transformative Industries emerge
in that time two of the key ones being
cyber security I mean cyber security
just wasn't even an industry 25 years
ago Northern Ireland has forged a path
to become the world leading Center for
cyber security but also we've had
creative Industries so Game of Thrones
was a big big deal here for a long time
but on the back of that an entire film
and television industry respond and
that's now bringing in a lot of other
revenues from the States since so I
think very good relationships uh been
established and having opportunities
like the president arriving today just
lets us further those and Foster them
all right Roger we've got to leave it
there uh best of luck with a visit
thanks for joining me today thank you
now recent results from Lloyds of London
highlighted the resilience of the
world's largest Insurance market and of
the growing demand for insurance while
meeting that demand is the job of the
syndicates which provide underwriting
capacity of the kind invested in by
Helios underwriting it has an unusual
business model in that it seeks not only
to generate income for investors from
its activity in Lloyd's it also actively
seeks to buy out former Lloyd's members
well it's just appointed a new chief
executive Martin wreath who joins me now
Martin welcome to you what sort of uh
capacity demand are you seeing right now
the demand for increased capacity is
very strong at the moment we're seeing a
huge demand for increased coverage
driven really by the uncertain world
that we live in today and our job at
Helios is to provide the syndicates that
we support within our portfolio as much
Capital as we can to allow them to
maximize those opportunities I was
talking to John Neal obviously the
Lloyd's CEO recently and we talked about
cyber in particular where premiums do
seem to be on the right is that an area
where you're looking to provide more
capacity yes I think so I mean one has
to be very mindful of systemic risk
within cyber uh so we we voluntarily
manage our portfolio quite carefully but
certainly cyber has been an area where
we've seen tremendous premium growth and
tremendous demand for the coverage are
there any pockets of the market where
there's over capacity
no I think uh generally the market is
very disciplined at the moment and I
think that's largely why we're seeing
the the robustness in the market that
John Neal referenced when you
interviewed him a couple of weeks ago uh
there's potentially some sliding in some
of the casualty sectors but but even so
rapes are still well in excess of where
they were three or four years ago so the
market generally is quite attractive and
which of the most profitable syndicates
at uh Helios has invested in over the
years so we have a portfolio uh across a
number of different syndicates some of
those are listed syndicates some of them
are not the key differential that we
bring to the party is that the Helios
investment model means that we have
Perpetual rights to participate in the
vast majority of the syndicates that we
back and that means that when there's
opportunities and there's preemptive
growth opportunities we can enjoy those
uh those growth moments you can get in
first and as I said in the introduction
you also buy out uh people who are
looking to sell limited liability
Vehicles where is the market right now
in that are there lots of people looking
to sell there's always a reasonable
interest in uh in Lloyd's names who have
llvs limited liability Vehicles looking
to exit the marketplace we are the only
listed Consolidated consolidator of
private Capital uh in the in the Lloyd's
market and I think there's been the sort
of stigma around private Capital noise
there's been sort of high barriers to
entry Helios is an aim listed vehicle
anybody can buy our shares and get
access to this exciting Market this
exciting time and when people do sell to
you do they tend to take the uh the the
the agreement in in shares do they carry
on remaining investors in you it's it's
a blend frankly that really individual
Choice clearly we're very keen to
increase our shareholder base and I
think our historic performance in that
we've outperformed the market has been
quite compelling for people to take
shares instead of cash people will be
quite I mean you mentioned they're the
Lloyd's names which is uh something that
older viewers will remember member of
course these individuals who down to
their last cufflinks of course face the
risk are there still many of those
people out there yeah there is actually
I mean Lloyd's private capital accounts
for about eight and a half percent of
the Lloyd's capacity at the moment so
it's still a very substantial part of
the marketplace and what motivates these
people to sell because you'd think
having gone through some really horrific
times back in the 1990s they'd be pretty
committed to being named absolutely but
the reality is that that often it's uh
it's aging uh names that are looking for
an exit or tragedy sometimes that it's
it's part of an estate so there's uh
often a large volume that we can look to
to acquire so if I'm a name selling up
or a descendant of a deceased name
perhaps is there a capital gains tax
liability when they sell there is no
capital gain sex liability I believe
yeah that's quite a good good thing now
uh recently uh you said that uh the
company said that acquisition
discussions had been put on hold due to
the invasion of Ukraine would you expect
this year to be busy and that as that uh
now the sort of turmoil associated with
that has uh died down well I'm not sure
I do actually I mean I think the reality
is
um Russia Ukraine we're still in the
grip of that Peril and and the losses
are potentially still unfolding there's
a number of headline losses that we're
familiar with but but as I say the the
loss is still maturing over time and and
the battle is still going on and in
terms of uh the overall health of the
Lloyd's markets it does look to be
pretty buoyant right now I mean why is
demand for insurance so robust around
the world
well it's a non-discretionary purchase
generally Insurance in this uncertain
world people tend to batten down the
hatches as best they possibly can uh
there's a lot of demand for the for the
uh for the products that we sell
um Demar demand is there and the Lloyd
of London Market is meeting that demand
as best it can and uh when I spoke to
John the other day he said he was trying
to get people back in the Lloyds
building on Monday which hadn't been the
case are you seeing plenty of people
coming back I think they're dribbling
back drips and drowns but but clearly
that's the heart of our market so it's
important that it does happen very good
here Nicholas good to see you this
morning thank you very much
some other stories for you now and the
Swiss Parliament has failed to approve
guarantees offered by the country's
government to rescue credit Swiss last
month the guarantee is worth some 109
billion Swiss francs are around 97
billion pounds were office credit Swiss
was bought by its larger rival UBS for 3
billion Swiss Francs well the deal which
is expected to lead to thousands of job
losses has been widely criticized in
Swiss Switzerland with a majority of the
public said to oppose it well the vote
is largely symbolic because the
government used emergency laws to pass
through the payments and the money has
already been committed
Joseph delaru fell by 23 this morning
after the banknote printer warned that
profits for the year will be worse than
expected the company which designs and
manufactures all circulating banknotes
in the UK also said that demand for Bank
loads had been at the lowest level for
more than 20 years resulting in a low
order book going into the next financial
year dolaro which also supplies
banknotes for countries including the
United Arab Emirates Fiji Egypt and
Thailand said it was talking to its
lending banks with the aim of amending
the terms governing its current
borrowing agreements
unite students the UK's leading provider
of student accommodation said this
morning it is expecting rental growth of
between six and seven percent for the
2023-24 Academic Year the company which
provides homes to 70 000 students in 23
leading University towns and cities said
reservations were significantly ahead of
recent sales Cycles reflecting strong
demand from both new and existing
students Richard Smith the chief
executive added that the supply of
purpose-built student accommodation
cannot keep Pace with growing student
demand at the same time as house in
multiple occupation landlords are
leaving the sector
I'm the chief executive of
InterContinental Hotels group the owner
of the Holiday Inn chain has warned that
the UK stock market is not a very
attractive place for listed companies
Keith Barr told the financial times that
several shareholders in the ftse 100
company had asked him at a recent
investor Roadshow whether he had any
plans to switch the company's primary
listing to the United States where his
com comments come after crh the world's
biggest building materials group said it
would move its main listing from London
to New York while the cambridge-based
chip designer arm Holdings shunned the
secondary London listing despite pleas
from the UK government to do so
now not many would dare to sue a
government when it nationalizes their
assets but that's exactly what
shareholders in the Energy company ypf
did after their business was confiscated
by the Argentine government in 2014 and
last week they won with the federal
court in the southern district of New
York ruling that the government of
Christina kirschner broke the law
damages between 10 and 20 billion
dollars may now be paid well joining me
is one of the one of one of the
architects of that successful claim
Amanda bellancor he's a partner at
Kepler cast Armando welcome to you are
we talking by and large about
institutional investors here or were
there some retail investors as well
okay thank you for for the invitation
good morning uh this is a unique case
um with uh
um a ruling that includes
um mention about the the rule of law the
practice to servanda and and this is
important news for for the economy we
include some effort doing many years to
obtain a good resolution
to avoid that the sovereign state could
uh not fulfill the rule of law and
practice social Banda and you know this
is important if a decision for investors
what were the main things that you had
to prove
uh I think what a a long a long way
after A.D are fighting in in U.S courts
and when Argentina Argentina decided to
um provides the yts company they include
some bylaws to protect the investor and
the rule the ruling just refer that the
the bylaws have to be fulfilled by the
governments to protect the investor even
if they are
listed in the U.S and and as a
protection for the investors
Argentina have to pay the damages for to
fail to comply with the bylos she has a
protection for investors when the
company has to include an investor sorry
as to investing in the company
has to be rise to to in this case to
receive the money for who decide to take
over the company and it was the ruling
include this is a
protection for investor this is a rule
of law this is practitioner this is the
most important part of the ruling
now this case concerned an Argentinian
subsidiary of a Spanish company with
mainly Spanish shareholders why was the
case being heard in New York
because the the company ypf
was listed in the also is listed in the
in the U.S
and even every investor in whatever
nationality of the investor we have the
right to go to the escort because the
the ideas the the titles that the
company in insolvency that I am the the
service interesting I have the right to
go to the U.S core because the
obligation
born in the in the in the ypf sorry in
the stock market in U.S
now can Argentina appeal against this
verdict this ruling yes the rule in two
weeks ago almost two weeks probably
Argentina will appeal we don't know
today what will be the next step
Argentina at for sure given that the
passage scenario on the Argentina track
record probably they will appear
and who will decide on the size of the
damages and what sort of things will
they be taking into account
yeah it will be the judge
will be decided by the after a hidden or
uh decision and a new decision in the in
the near future
uh but the the most important of the of
the things that really include some
parameters that they have to be
considered to evaluate the diamond the
final damages that Argentina has to pay
to the Peterson companies
Argentina's government is pretty
cash-strapped right now it's negotiating
with the international monetary fund are
they going to be in a position to pay
out damages
all the days all the state have to be
fulfilled with the all the rulings and I
don't see any country in mangaroo it's
impossible Argentina will have to pay
um we we don't know what time we we
success to recover the final amount of
the damages but we're supposed at the
some states Argentina will fulfill the
obligations and then compare with the
rule
all right it's a fascinating story
Armando appreciate you joining us today
to talk about it thank you God bless you
for me thank you very much
still to come here on inking live we'll
have a look at how Global markets are
doing this morning don't go away
[Music]
well last night's mixed session on Wall
Street was followed by a largely
positive trading overnight in the Asia
Pacific region Hong Kong finished down
by more than one percent or roughly one
percent but elsewhere there were games
in Tokyo Sydney Shanghai and in Mumbai
which isn't on the screen in Europe
Equity markets a little move this
morning ahead of the U.S inflation
figures this lunchtime you can see all
the main Continental European indices
are in positive territory though talking
points this morning include Volvo the
truck maker is up some seven and a half
percent in Stockholm after it reported a
record quarterly profit well here in
London the ftse 100 is also in positive
territory currently some 47 points to
the good that's up nearly two-thirds of
one percent in a broad-based rally the
leading gainer in the ftse right now in
percentage terms is centrica that's as
it's uh share buyback continues the
shares uh up two percent right now but
there are very few features quite
frankly for investors to hang their hats
on this morning another notable Gainer
is Fraser's group that follows the March
retail sales figures yesterday from the
British retail taught him which are
better than expected phrases group
currently up on some one and a half
percent or so outside the ftse the
property group great Portland Estates is
ahead by some three-quarters of one
percent on a trading update while the
online electrical retailer marks reads
electrical we've had them on the program
in the recent past they're up seven
percent after reporting record full year
sales on the foreign exchange markets
well it's pretty quiet ahead of the US
inflation data Sterling little changed
against the dollar they're down a tenth
to one percent it's off by uh just under
a fifth of one percent against the Euro
The single currency meanwhile up a ten
to one percent against the Greenback as
for the oil price all that continues to
trade in a very tight range Following
last week's news on OPEC plus production
cuts a pound of Brent crude will
currently cost you
85.74 cents a barrel that is up
one-sixth of one percent will joining me
this morning is killer Kinko's Rachel
winter Rachel good to see you this
morning
um we mentioned uh unite uh earlier on
in the program really a very positive
trading update indeed yes indeed so this
is the UK's lead leading student
property developer they provide homes
for about 70 000 students here in the UK
I think we've got a lot of international
students coming to the UK not
necessarily from Europe but from India
and China so that's been very good for
them so this morning they said they have
booked out over 90 percent of their
rooms for the next academic year I'm
raising uh rents by between six and
seven I expect suspect only parents of
kids going off to University this Autumn
will have winced when they heard that
they will so yes it's not good for the
parents that costs will be going up but
for unite because the cost of their debt
will be rising I don't see they have
little choice but to raise their rents
to uh to cover those costs so now
another one that's caught your eye this
morning is petrified Oil Services Group
yeah I think it's been a very difficult
decade actually for oil services uh
because the oil price actually since
2014 has been relatively low with the
exception of the last year so the oil
and Majors have really been trying to
cut their costs and that means spending
less money with these oil services
companies we've also seen investors
really not wanting oil and Majors to
invest in new exploration so that's
about news for oil services companies as
well so we've had an update from
petrifact this morning and they've
actually increased the costs of a lot of
their current projects and they expect
to make a bigger than expected loss for
this year I mean another big player in
the sector Wood Group has just had a
couple of takeover approaches I mean
could petrifax current weakness flush
out a bit of there do you think
possibly I mean the shares have come
down a huge amount so potentially there
could be an attractive takeover Target
now that the market cap is relatively
low now another one of the stock markets
walking wounded De La Rue it just goes
from bad to worse yeah I've just lost
count of how many profit warnings there
have been here I remember this company
being in the ftse 100s it then got
relegated to the 250 and last year it
came out of the 250. this morning it's
probably worth about 70 million pounds
so it really has come down a huge amount
the fact is it's a company that prints
banknotes and we're not using those as
much as we used to as of this morning
apparently we're at a 20-year low for
the demands for banknotes and I think
covid really has accelerated the move
away from printed money to online
payments and that's clearly bad news for
Delaney yeah I mean it does loads of
other stuff as well though I mean it
prints passports it provides all sorts
of validation services for governments
is there a good business fighting to get
out here is it just to saddle with its
past there are some good parts I think
most of the money at the moment does
come from currency it did used to print
passports for the UK but sadly it lost
that contract in 2020 so I think even
those good parts of the business are
showing decline in some areas yeah now
another update we've had there aren't
many of it you've done well to uh pick
out the ones where there is interesting
stuff going on today we've had an update
from De Beers which of course is
controlled by anglo-american yeah so
they've published their latest rough
diamond sales and they've actually said
that sales have been quite resilient and
they are seeing increasing demand from
China for Diamond jewelry so I just
thought this could give some interesting
read across for the luxury sector
because that has been surprisingly
strong over the last year despite the
cost of living crisis and we have got
results later on from lvmh so we'll have
to see how those look as well well of
course France's biggest company in an
absolute Bellwether for the luxury
sector what are you expecting there I
think good results I think they've had a
really good year Louis Vuitton which is
their Flagship brand has been doing
incredibly well and I think people are
moving away from Fast fashion towards
more quality products which is good news
for the luxury sector all right gotta
leave it there Rachel great to have you
here in the studio today thank you thank
you
still to come here on Ian King live I'm
going to be joined by the chief
executive of Novo Holdings
in the multi-billion life science sector
they've just published their annual
results don't go away
foreign
welcome back now it's been impossible
lately to miss the headlines surrounding
the weight loss drug drug wargovi which
was developed by Novo Nordisk the
world's biggest manufacturer of insulin
well both Novo Nordisk which is
Denmark's largest company and its sister
company novozymes are controlled by the
Novo Nordisk Foundation which is the
world's biggest charitable Foundation
it's assessed totaling 805 billion
Danish crowns which is around 95 billion
pounds are in turn managed by Novo
Holdings or today it announced it
received income of 3 billion Danish
crowns that's 354 million pounds in 2022
as investment returns fell by five
percent joining me now is the chief
executive of Novo Holdings qasim kute
kasim very good to see you this morning
thank you very much a return of minus
five percent doesn't sound great but
actually you beat your benchmark and
that was actually pretty good given it
was a rotten year for investing it was
uh Ian I mean it's never good to be in
negative territory but 2022 was a very
challenging year on many fronts as we
all know so on relative basis we're
actually quite satisfied by the six by
the minus six percent we're particularly
satisfied in the sense that uh the
diversification that we've been pursuing
for the last four years uh both from an
asset class and Geographic perspective
really helped mitigate against a
negative equity market so all in all
not a bad performance on a relative
basis so how does the portfolio break
down between equities and fixed income
for example yeah so the portfolio is
very heavily weighted towards equities
both in terms of private and public
Equity so it's uh over 60 equities and
then we've got the rest made up of bonds
real estate infrastructure
and some other Alternatives as well and
what components of the uh Equity uh
Holdings are in life sciences and I
presume Nova and all disk itself is a
pretty meaningful yeah Nova Nordisk is a
big big chunk but we do divide our
business between its two component parts
so we've got what we call the Holdings
which is our controlling shareholding
and noven orders can Nova Zions then
we've got the Investment Portfolio
so in terms of our total assets so if
you put both of those combined obviously
Northern orders is the biggest chunkers
and open orders today is the second
largest company in Europe by market
value but if if you look at the
Investment Portfolio itself then Life
Sciences accounts for about
50 percent of the overall allocation so
we do have a very heavy weighting
towards Healthcare now you've been
pretty positive on the UK biotech sector
why is that well we're positive on the
biotech sector broadly speaking so
biotech is at a very interesting
juncture of course what's making the
headlines today is the big correction
that happened in the sector about 18
months ago big big downturn but the
reality is we were in acid bubble
territory before that so in many ways
it's a healthy correction of course
there's a lot of dislocation that
happens with corrections but it's a
healthy one because we were not in a
good place before it was truly asset
bubble territory
uh the reason why we're very bullish is
that we are in a golden era of
innovation that Innovation started about
10 years ago and it has a long tail to
run so we're really at the beginning or
the tip of the iceberg in terms of cell
and gene therapy and what mRNA is going
to deliver of course I'm going to
deliver the phenomenal vaccines that we
had during covet but all of those
technologies have a long way to run and
the UK of course is a major life science
Hub so we're actively investing in
biotech in the UK but as we are in the
US as well and in other parts of Europe
and the beauty of the foundation means
that you can take long-term decisions I
mean you are patient Capital we are very
patient Capital we're very blessed to be
able to take the long-term View and by
taking the long-term view actually we
are really putting
um we were really ramping up our
investments in biotech both in the UK
and elsewhere because valuations are
very attractive today there's a lot of
assets companies that we've been
following for many years where today
they are were able to invest at 30 40
percent and cheaper than where they were
perhaps two years ago and if you take
the long-term View and you believe in
the power of the Innovation I was
talking about then this is a very good
time to be investing with a long-term
lens now you mentioned just now that you
have been reallocating uh Capital within
the portfolio what are going to be the
the big investment themes that dictate
what you do this year it's going to be
more of the same we will continue to
allocate a significant portion of our
portfolio to life sciences and
Healthcare and there we invest across
the continuums we're investing from the
seed almost company startup phase than
to venture to growth and what we call
principal Investments which are the big
buyouts so we'll continue to do that but
we will also continue with our
Geographic diversification we want to do
more in Asia we are investing in bigger
buyouts in the US and then importantly I
mentioned earlier the diversification in
certain areas that helped us
um generate the relatively good
performance and that was going into
areas like real estate like in
infrastructure like credit high yield
bonds we will continue to ramp those up
right now you've just engineered
Denmark's biggest merger between
novozymes and Christian Hansen what's
the rationale there yeah I'm glad you
asked that question Ian because I for us
that is a truly a milestone within the
novo group uh it's reminiscent of the
merger that took place many years ago
between Nova and nordis that created the
global giant that we have today so what
we're doing is bringing together two
companies where we are a major
shareholder to create the world's
leading biosolutions Powerhouse and
biosolutions is a very interesting area
it's not one that a lot of people know
about it's quite an esoteric field but
it's essentially biotech Solutions not
for human health but for industry and
it's basically replacing fossil fuel
based ingredients and synthetic
ingredients so it plays a very critical
part in the green infrastructure and if
you believe in the decarbonization
agenda both from a sustainability
perspective but both from a financial
return perspective this field makes a
huge amount of sense because Under One
Roof we're putting two complementary
Technologies together the enzyme
capabilities of novozymes the bacterial
capabilities of Christian Hansen able to
offer our customers that holistic
technology solution it sounds absolutely
fascinating there's loads more I wanted
to ask you casting but we're out of time
before you'll you'll have to come back
with pleasure thank you for having me
good to see you thank you
foreign
[Music]
have a look at this morning's business
pages and the financial times leads its
print edition with news at ey her scrap
plans to break up its audit and
Consulting businesses after months of
internal disagreement and opposition
from Executives in the United States
it's currently leading its Digital
Editions with a report that tens of
thousands of Hong kongers who moved to
the UK are being blocked from accessing
as much as 2.2 billion pounds worth of
pension assets by the Hong Kong
government the times also leads its
business pages with ey's decision not to
break itself up but the paper also
carries comments from Alistair Phillips
Davis he's the chief executive of SSE in
which he says the government will fail
to secure any new wind farms through a
recently launched auction because the
financial support on offer
insufficiently reflects soaring costs
Daily Telegraph meanwhile leads with the
dismissal yesterday of the CBI director
General Tony danker it also carries on
its business front page news that the
U.S Economist Megan green a prominent
critic of brexit is to join the bank of
England's rate setting monetary policy
committee for joining me this morning is
the times as economics correspondent RT
natia fan Arty good to see you this
morning
um let's start with uh Megan green I
mean this is a very big appointment by
the uh banksia of course replaces one of
the NPC's Uber doves
exactly so sylvanero has been on the
committee since 2017 she's had a big
influence on it on the direction of
monetary policy and she has voted to
against rate Rises for the last three
meetings and has indicated as well that
she might vote for a rate cut before the
end of her term in July now we've seen
from Megan green she has some commentary
in the financial times she said in March
that she's a little bit concerned that
the rising in interest rates across the
world and quantitative tightening could
pose some threats to financial stability
so that indicates a somewhat dovish
position but I think the fact that she
is replacing sylvana who is kind of the
archdove on the committee I think that
kind of but de facto moves the committee
into slightly more hawkish territory now
whether that will actually impact the
direction of future monetary policy is
less clear because we've got the the
contingent that are more dovish we've
got the contingent that are more hawkish
Catherine Mann and others and then we've
got the central ones including the
governor and they've repeatedly said
that they're more likely to be swayed by
the data that we're getting in what
we're seeing on jobs wage Rises what
we're seeing on inflation and so they'll
be focusing more on that so whether the
appointment is significantly going to
change the path to monetary policy that
we're expecting at the moment is unclear
but unlikely yeah want to follow that
now the CBI of course is everywhere
you've got a big piece in the times this
morning on it I mean the the coverage is
pretty hostile across the board isn't it
I think it comes at a time for the CBI
where there is a lot of Reckoning not
just the cultural Reckoning but also in
terms of strategy I mean the the damage
to their reputation that these
allegations have done will make it a lot
more difficult for the CBI to lobby and
they rely on their membership for about
90 of their income so it's also whether
the CBI is able to get businesses back
on board convince people that they can
rehabilitate their reputation and be
able to effectively Lobby because we're
in a time where a lot of businesses are
struggling their costs are rising
they're facing economic uncertainty so
it's from several different angles that
the CBI really has to rehabilitate quite
quickly and I think that it's quite
clear that they have gone for Speed
overdue process which could be a risky
decision they've brought back Wayne
Newton Smith after him after she left
only a month ago and was part of the
executive board but not going through a
formal recruitment process which is not
thought to have happened could also be
another risk for them
now you've chosen another uh story which
I was very pleased to see you chose
actually uh the the telegrapher put the
imf's forecasting record under the
microscope as well they might I can't
understand why we give the IMF so much
respect I mean it's forecasting record
is rotten
especially with the UK it has under
forecasted for quite a few years now and
I think that it is time that we that we
question their processes but the the
good point I think that is made in the
telegraph art school is working to a few
economists on this is the fact that it's
not necessarily a bias but it's more
old-fashioned processes bureaucracy and
the IMF is looking at data on the UK
from a few months ago to judge where we
are now the problem is that economic
shops are much more frequent in recent
years and also the fact that we're much
more interdependent you know even the
the risks from the the Swiss banking
system on Global Financial stability and
and we're much more kind of open to
shocks from other economies affecting
our growth potential so there's a few
things that call for a lot of these
International bodies to update their
forecasting processes now the IMF has
been around since 1944 and I think what
is clear from this is that that
modernization is needed for forecasters
to be a lot quicker on their feet but it
does also raise the question of why the
UK because they not consistently under
forecasting for other economies
no absolutely I think I'd rather ask my
next-door neighbors cat what the economy
will do next year than the IMF anyway
Artie got to leave it there good to see
you this morning
my hours interest rates Rose sharply
last year the fundraising environment
became harder for a lot of startups and
growth companies yet there was one
source of capital which remained in
decidedly good health The Venture
Capital trust or VT CT sector figures
just published by the Association of
investment companies revealed that in
the tax year just ended some 1.08
billion pounds was raised by vcts that
was the second highest fundraising ever
and down just five percent on the record
tax year of 2021-22 will joining me now
is Richard Stone he is the chief
executive of the association of
investment companies Richard good to see
you this morning are you surprised that
fundraising remains so robust given the
the broader investment backdrop
um I don't think so particularly when
you look at what Venture Capital trusts
are investing in you know they're really
investing in the young ambitious
companies in the economy and helping
provide vital capital for them and I
think from an Investor's point of view
there's a real appetite to get involved
and to support those businesses so yeah
as is clearly a good sign of Health for
that part of the economy yeah now in the
last calendar year vct's invested 700
million pounds in growth companies that
suggests that there's still a fair bit
of dry powder left to be put to use yes
I mean Venture Capital trusts raise
money in the tax year and then they have
sort of three years to then invest that
money so uh it it does take a little
while for that money to filter through
to the to the companies
um it's also important to remember that
Venture Capital trusts often invest more
than once in the same company so over
the last five years they've made about a
thousand investments in over 500
companies but some of those are
follow-on investments so a young company
will need Capital at a point in time and
then further on its Journey it may need
a little bit more and then a bit more
and Venture Capital trust can provide
that flow so that's another important
part of what they do now the treasury
has been hinting that is going to review
the uh the tax privileges associated
with vcts do you think that those that's
been put to bed now those concerns
um yeah I mean I think you know it's
it's very clear that Venture Capital
trusts fill a very important Gap within
the sort of funding Spectrum for
businesses and and support those younger
ambitious companies in their growth
plans
um the scheme the tax advantages of the
scheme come to an end in legislative
terms in April 2025 the government's
very helpfully announced that they will
be looking to extend that scheme
um The Windsor framework bizarrely there
was a a an aspect of the Northern
Ireland protocol that impacted this uh
that should free that up free the
government up to do that now so we're
really just awaiting the detail from the
government and hopefully that will come
sort of by the time of the Autumn
statement so it gives some longevity
this scheme's been around for 27 years
so through many different political Hues
and uh it deserves that long-term
stability yeah I mean a lot of people uh
think that the current popularity is
because people who've maxed out on their
pensions and don't want to hit the
lifetime allowance have been going into
vcts instead now the lifetime allowance
has been scrapped is there a danger that
that deprives the VC sector of capital
um I don't think so I mean although the
lifetime allowance has been scrapped
actually
um the the taper down on the amount that
you can put into your pension Still
Remains um quite significant for those
higher earners who are investing so I
don't think it will have an effect and
as I said Venture Capital trusts are
investing in a particular group of
businesses within the economy they're
providing investors with a diversified
access to those Investments that they
wouldn't necessarily be able to get
elsewhere and you know the average VCT
Investments about 33 000 pounds so it's
not you know the high net worth end of
the market that you might perhaps
anticipate that's interesting I didn't
know that what about the nature of
investment I mean obviously by
definition these are risky Investments
not every company that a VCC backs will
succeed do you carry any statistics on
how many VCT businesses fail yeah I
think it's about 60 percent uh sold the
the of the Investments are sold at a
loss and about 40 at a profit so yeah
this is high risk investment and that's
the benefit to the investor investing in
a venture capital trust is you're
getting access to a portfolio so a
typical Venture Capital trust will have
somewhere between 30 and 50 investee
companies that they're invested in so
that you hope that the winners outweigh
the the losers in terms of the the
financial outcome but yeah this is this
is high risk investment and that's
partly why you have to have the tax
breaks to encourage the money in in the
first place all right Richard good to
see you this morning thank you very much
thank you
just a reminder for you of what we are
expecting to see very shortly we are
waiting for President Biden to appear
this is the scene right now in York
Street in Belfast security is on high
alert very obviously as they await the
arrival of the president to open the new
Belfast Campus of the University of
Ulster we think President Biden at this
current moment is holding talks with the
Prime Minister we're expecting to see
some pictures of that meeting very
shortly uh details too hopefully of what
the two men have been talking about we
will be hoping to bring you that uh live
I can tell you that is a very very quiet
uh York Street there I've been I've been
down there and uh it's normally a
considerably uh busier than that so
there's obviously a considerable uh
police presence and security presence in
place
now during the last winter many of us
will have been reminded of the
importance of having emergency home
repair provision amid burst pipes and
packed up boilers well among the big
players in the market are British gas
and home surf but there's also a
Challenger in the market in the shape of
home tree Group which today announced
it's completed a 46 million dollar
series B funding round its backers
include the specialist energy and
sustainability investors 2150 and energy
impact partners and legal and general
Capital are joining me now is Simon
Phelan he's founder and chief executive
of Home tree Simon welcome to you I mean
this uh funding round was over
subscribed you could have raised more
yes we were very fortunate in that
um you know there was a pocket of
capital in in climate and sustainability
funds who are looking for growth
businesses that are having an increased
impact and I guess we were fortunate
enough to to hit some of their criteria
so what do you what is this thing going
to enable you to do so look our Core
Business as you as you reference is
competing in the in the in the home
emergency Insurance Market against the
British gases and the Home Service of
the world we're going to continue to
grow that business but really in the
opportunity that we see is homeowners
are being put under pressure by
governments and you know by other
um stakeholders to start to decarbonize
their homes moved from gas boilers to
heat pumps but solar on the roof and
home tree believes that we have an
opportunity to play a role there in
helping them to do that and you've also
announced an acquisition today you
bought a green financing business called
be warm yes so exactly in line with what
I outlined in terms of our strategy we
partnered with this company be warm a
number of years ago where our homeowners
when they get to a point in their
Journey where the actual heating system
can no longer be repaired and needs to
be replaced they typically come to home
tree to look for a upgrade
you know hopefully in the future to more
heat pumps than gas boilers but really
you know we find again and again
homeowners are looking for financing
solutions to help cover The Upfront cost
because as you know these these systems
are expensive and so for us we believe
there's a significant opportunity in
having a suite of financing products in
loans leasing type solutions that can
help homeowners overcome The Upfront
cost But ultimately get the the
long-term benefit of these Green
Solutions I mean if you've put your
finger on a really good point though I
mean the cost of these heat pumps is
terrifyingly expensive yeah look it's
like any renewable technology these have
a cost curve which you know in the case
of EVS today has come down significantly
over the last 10 years and we've seen
more and more mass adoption I see more
Teslas on the road all the time we are
at an earlier stage in the evolution of
of heat pumps and other Technologies for
decarbonizing our homes but
fundamentally as we've learned over the
last 12 24 months and you know we can't
be reliant on foreign gas to heat our
homes we need to become self-reliant in
terms of our Energy Systems and how we
heat and power our homes so I think the
impetus is there the the the market is
is gearing up governments are gearing up
and we believe that Solutions such as
new financing offerings and kind of
service providers like home tree have a
real role to play in adopting the the
category that is fascinating I mean why
do you think the the banks aren't doing
this I mean surely they could be selling
uh heat pump Solutions as part of a
mortgage package couldn't they you know
look it's a great question I think
clearly
um we've seen in the U.S that the the
Home Improvements sustainable Home
Improvement Market
um it is a is a challenging category you
know you have hundreds of thousands of
Engineers going into people's homes you
know there's only so much control that
Banks can have and so what we've seen is
that the real winners tend to be
specialists in the Home Services space
who have
um you know direct relationships with
the homeowners but also direct
relationships with the engineer base who
are really the front line of you know
solving climate change in terms of
decarbonizing our homes and so at home
tree really in our DNA is not just an
obsession with the customer but no
obsession with these engineers and
installers we want to try and make them
more successful by wrapping around
things like financing insurance and let
them do what they're so wonderful at
doing which is installing this green
hardware and homes all right Simon we've
got to leave it there good to see you
this morning and well done on the
fundraising it's a tough environment
right now so thank you nice to have a
good news story thank you
that's it from me there's much more on
the Sky News Mobile app and on our
digital platforms where right now you
can actually see a piece by me on the
defenestration of Tony danker the CBI
director General yesterday do have a
look at that if you possibly can well
I'm back at 10 o'clock tomorrow morning
hope very much to see you then in the
meantime do stay tuned up next it's
Sally Lockwood and my colleague Kamali
Melbourne who's over in Belfast where
would be bringing you all the latest
from President Biden's visit don't go
away cheerio
foreign